madame marois est ce qui apparaît ce que
c'est pas assez délicat quand même que
ce soit votre mari alors que vous
aspiriez à devenir première ministre qui
faisait du financement pour vous quel
message envoie parce que cette proximité
avec vous madame marois pour beaucoup de
gens que votre mari vient de faire du
sud de la sollicitation c'est un peu
comme si vous vous aimez vous savez dans
toute ma vie politique et ça fait 35 ans
que je suis en politique
jamais on a pu attaquer mon intégrité et
je j'ai vite qui que ce soit a identifié
un projet une intervention dans laquelle
j'aurais j'aurais participé et qui
auraient avantagé une entreprise une
société une personne je suis à cet égard
absolument irréprochable
c'est le fondement de mon engagement
politique n'avait jamais je devais
accepter qu'on fasse des pressions sur
la base qu'on ait pu financer ma
formation politique que ce soit mais
députés que ce soit des militants ou mon
mari qui est sollicité des fonds